--docteur percheron je crois que nous
sommes en plein coeur de l'aisne nous
sommes plutôt oui nous sommes
géographiquement à peu près dans le
cadre de l'indh dans le centre tout au
moins de l'inde du nord et nous sommes
surtout au coeur du pays musulmans alors
voici faty pour cycles qui est une ville
située sur la douma h 30 dimanche une
des trois rivières saintes de l'inde
eh bien ça crée de l'ami et qui a été
fondée par les grands moghols c'est une
véritable forteresse que l'homme sage
est la leur c'est extraordinaire ce que
cette ville qu'est bon dieu pas trop mal
conservés évident en chine win comme si
un jour les habitants étaient partis
n'avaient rien et c'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est ce qui se passe et pour
quelle raison ne s'est pas révolution de
palais les grands moghols y ait eu des
dissensions à la croix des grands mots
boys ont remplacé des uns les autres et
7 se fatiguer qui était une des
capitales a été abandonné par le
successeur d'un gran mogol gb disent pas
et depuis personne n'a eue l'an non
c'est conserver ça c'est conserver ça
peut pas été respectée par le temps par
les hommes
vous voyez quelques musulmans qui
viennent là la mosquée est encore
fréquenté et voilà un tombeau d'un des
grands moghols c'est aussi je crois le
ton bout d'une femme parce qu'il était
plat il n'avait pas pris ce même sur la
dalle supérieure avant les femmes n'ont
pas droit à un prix ce n'est maintenant
pas leurs impôts c'est ce qui
différencie des tangos ses décors
extrêmement slim moussa défier des
sièges sapeurs homérique des sièges des
sites et c'était très décoré comme vous
dites c'est le style le style indien
le musulman qu'un seizième siècle 16e
siècle était la grande époque nationale
c'est dû être construit pierre par
pierre d'envoyer des femmes musulmanes
ça c'est une chose tout à fait
qu'étonnante elles sont vêtues par
dessus leurs vêtements d'un long suaire
blanc qui leur tombe jusqu'aux pieds qui
est accroché à une couronne sur la tête
avait que deux ouvertures probablement
les yeux grillagée de la nba c'est
épouvantable avoir ces spectrale et
pourquoi c'est une main à grands noms
afin de ne va pas à montrer son visage
et vous apercevez un pet gnagnagna
l'éclair brin quelquefois c'est
peut-être de très jolis l'amener ne les
regardais pas propre à vous étiez
enrayer un mauvais coup d'oeil pas moins
l'homme qui est à coup et moi je pouvais
à la quelque chose que nous allons
retrouver tout à l'heure c'est cette
décoration d'incruster de marbre de
marbre blanc
et d'incrustations la de marne sur
marbre ou marveaux sur noir sur marbre
blanc et marbre gris
c'est ravissant et rêve indien dont 7,2
mais c'était avec des pierres de couleur
ou au taj mahal envoie des fleurs la
grandeur des fleurs naturelles cueillies
par exemple une anémone qui est formé de
jeu j'en ai compté une fois sur une 35
petit pierre différentes pour fait une
flotte
vous dire je t'aime aussi des indiens et
des indiennes parce que bien que ça soit
musulman tu as et voilà une annonce
voilà un des tombeaux d'un des grands
nombres de gran mogol plutôt de quoi
c'est en bout d'un de ses premiers me
sens mieux mais voilà le mage noir taj
mahal j'ai plein de respect n'est ce pas
qu'on se tape l'inde respect plein
d'amour aussi je pourrais l'appeler le
ton bout d'une infâme défunte
non mais mieux que ce ne fut pas une
infante c'est hélas la favorite la
deuxième ou troisième épouse de chats
géants chan germes qui a été un des plus
beaux rôles et qui aimait tellement ça
peu favori qui devait donner roxy dit
fils qu' il y avait le plus beau
monument est mené par une voie la seule
grande coupole est le symbole de la
maternité
oui alors elle se détache au dessus de
cette porte monumentale avec l on
excepte par des escaliers en bas des
escaliers tout le monde laisse ses
chaussures parce que nous entrons dans
un édifice musulmans puis surtout aussi
pour ne pas abîmer les marbres ce sera
moins crimes d' abîmer ses bobards et
ses quatre minarets que nous reverrons
tout à l'heure je vous propose une
expérience et de la main de les cacher
la droite et à gauche
cachan et la coupole à ce moment là
n'est plus équilibré il faut cette
liaison entre eux cette coupole centrale
un paysage et le fait que quatre
minarets
c'est extraordinaire a compris ça
s'éteint un architecte qui s'appelait
vous affirmera boldin qui en ce sens 40
est venue de
du quoi rythme c'est à dire la paix ni
sens actuel pour construire ce
magnifique trône elle en charge et à
décharge n avais propos avaient eu lundi
de même reposer à côté de ses favoris en
face de l'autre côté le rayonnement
il avait fait construire un autre
tombeau semblabes un peu plus grands
sables mandat sous le charme
mais la mort est arrivé avant que ça ne
soit tout à fait fini a alors pour la
nes et on a laissé se tombola on a pas
chez le pont marbre blanc qui devait
unir même à l'otan passe en dessous
d'elle demain et il a demandé à reposer
aux côtés de
tu as mal la désirable les arbres
admirable et alors plein de petit
perroquet vert d'espèces de grandes
perruches avec une très longue que de 30
ou 40 cm qui jacassent qui font un bruit
alors c'est beau miroir d'eau dans
lesquels se réflète taj mahal est aussi
bull matin que le sai on dirait qu'il
est en marbre blanc il est dans des
fermes arbre blanc ligne toutes les
couleurs il est tantôt verte en toub le
temps toro santoro or your utile comme
de l'or oui cindy il reflète en fait
tout ce qu'il s'agit d'une crise il est
avant tout jouer journée je ne connais
que le parthénon à l'acropole ne soit
capable de se transformer comme le taj
mahal mais je crois que c'est une des
choses que nous préférer en ce moment
c'est l'une des plus belles choses quand
on retrouve adam même qu'il y ait deux
fausses il faut voir dans la khl bénarès
mitage mal ça vaut la peine de pareloup
et abusent souvent même simplement en
noir et blanc c'est assez impressionnant
c'est émouvant c'est très émouvant et
alors et le chat n'avait fait venir pour
décorer des céramistes italiens qui ont
formé
régnant les artistes indiens pour les
incrustations là vous voyez les versets
du coran en noir sur blanc est alors à
l'intérieur sur les thromboses sur les
colonnes ce sont des accusations de
bière de pierres précieuses de couleurs
de chalcédoine les marines même dit rémi
à certains endroits et qui sont
tellement bien à raser la surface que
même sur les surfaces comme vous pouvez
passer longue jamais où il décrochera
quelque chose c'est que ces points de
vue et tout ceci est en marbre sculpté
et tout ceci a été construit du vivant
du liban reid du vivant alors à
l'intérieur au centre sous la coupole
centrale et le tombeau de moon passe mal
oui le donnait à lui offert un
magnifique joaillier hasek six premières
est alors à côté
il a mis son temps - de la famille est
au centre et lamia côté facilement
rappel n'a pas voulu déranger mais ce ne
sont que des cénotaphes les deux tombes
ou sont en dessous exactement la
réplique de ce qu'on voit dans la salle
centrale et sur celui du chat en avait
posé à la hauteur de sa tête un énorme
diamant
oui j'ai vu le lan photos étaient de
trois centimètres le diamètre des filles
a été d'essayer
laurent temps les cas nous narrait tu te
la coupole chantal ya une grande
terrasse deux ans domine tout le paysage
le paysage se doit dire n'est pas très
bonne est un peu plat c'est la grande
plaine alluvionnaires et une halte
animal a envoyé à ses sables ne vend
pense que cette doumaja autrefois avoir
un court beaucoup plus large
ou alors se déplacer à voir certains
couvrent les uns à côté des autres et
puis tout s'est unifiée mais nous allons
la voir tout à leur banc son ennui
actuelle elle passe devant la ville
d'agra qui est à 7 km et elle longe le
taj mahal et alors elle s'en va ensuite
se jeter dans le gange à la main à la
havane c'est vraiment une vision
extrêmement reposante
ces jardins sont magnifiques et les
pelouses sur les blues ont été disposés
des massifs depuis qu'ils représentent
des versets du coran
faut voir le taj mahal aussi de nuit de
ennuis de mai lorsque la lune reflète
sont refaites derrière la coupole
centrale et dans l'alignement dans l'axé
exactement des miroirs d'eau oui c'est
assez extraordinaire vision sont très
bas et qu'ils sont très bien entretenus
il ya beaucoup de quitter vous savez en
inde pour le passé c'est un pic
historique à 7,1 vautours la kilian's
passé il y en a beaucoup
ils font la voirie we7 c'est commode
cela traduit en grec
autrefois ses coupoles que vous voyez là
où était surmonté de deux croissants en
or mais ce n'est plus que du cuivre doré
cas cela aussi a disparu ont été pillés
c'est un manque de respect frémion on
n'a pas abîmé trop vous voyez tout de
même
c'est admirable proportions
et en décibels parce que mes dessins
oui c'est justement c'est ce que je
regarde c'est cette simplicité
extraordinaire donne une impression
étrange équilibre et qui apportent leur
faut pourquoi que c'est ça il ya dans le
détail le détail de l'incrustation ne
gêne pas 1
on ne le voit pas comment il faut
s'approcher dessus pour le voir mais il
ne nuit aucunement une surcharge aucune
vente n'est pas craignant donc je ne
vois pas non
ça donne simplement des reliefs plus
clair au plus foncé
venez voir un rat palmiste d'un petit
écureuil ans en politique comme les
autres et ça se sent des corneilles
encore michael we luv très mal hier une
surpêche les un peu mordant réel se
perche sur vos épaules elle vous donne
des petits coups de bec dans la nuque
c'est une familiarité vous dire mon dieu
nous sommes amis en mai au mail ben oui
nous sommes amis
il ya toujours des visiteurs journée
visiteurs je vous dis naturellement
beaucoup de musulmans mais les indiens
bienne et il ya cette espèce eux
tolérance mutuelle ça c'est de la
sculpture des sculptures sur les armes
à côté il ya d'autres monuments qui dans
une enceinte qui retourne au taj mahal
et ceux ci et là c'était la mort en face
et d'une mosquée mais ça avait été le
temps bout du bar gay de chagey un
barbier qui était un peu comme le
barbier nous ayons à l'origine de ces
éminences grises presque premiers fruits
voilà voilà la double la douma qui vient
dé du tibet qui coule le sensiblement
parallèle orange les qui se jette dans
le gange ou plutôt dans la gang à
puisque valérie blais s'est fait mine
arrivé à je crois que c'est la docteure
que nous allons achever ce merveilleux
voyage grâce à vous et je vous en
remercie infiniment
yann chaillot vous a proposé voyage sans
passeport sa démission a été réalisé
avec le concours du docteur percheron et
de solange péters montage pierre michel
rey sont annie du v10 script nathalie de
muret illustration sonore denise glaser